ですから 一応集中力生まれると
多かれ少なかれ一つ二つは体験しなくちゃ
体験するんです この十種類あります
この十種類の中に一つ二つは大体は体験しちゃうんです
そこはできればまあ 1 日で終わってもらわないと
あるいは二 三秒で 一本
二本でその状況をやめてもらわないと
もうそこでピッタシとストップなんです
そういうふうにストップになったり
人々は結構見てきたんです
そこまでもう何年も修行なんですよ
何年もヴィパッサナーやってそこまで来るんですけど
そこに来たら何か光が見えたとか
サマーディが生まれたとか
すごい確信が生まれたとか
そこでストップやっちゃう
それ言いたくて言いたくて
人に だから そこでまたそういう人々は諦めずに瞑想もします
よく瞑想する ちょっと暇があったらすぐ瞑想に入ると
子供たちと喧嘩までして
もうすぐ道場に行って瞑想に行っちゃうとかね
そういうふうにやる気もあるんだけど
本人は一箇所に留まっているんですね
いけないんです ですから
ウバッキレーサ 障害だと
だから本当に今までのヴィパッサナーというのはやりにくくて
難しくて 間違いばっかしで
失敗ばっかしで もうやっとやってきたもんなんですよ
で やっとスムーズにいけるようになったところで
ヴィパッサナーというのは
これスムーズになったことは問題だと
光なんか見えたりするとかなり気持ちいいんですね
で 渾身睡眠は全くないんですよ
この光が見えると 正しいヴィパッサナーの障害だったらね
ヴィパッサナーの障害として光が見えると昏睡睡眠はない
頑張ってるんだからね
で 妄想雑念もない で やっぱりそこはまあ障害だと
神秘体験は一つも認めてないんです
この軽安という軽く感じる場合はゼロで感じちゃうんですよ
体重は 時々ゼロで感じちゃうと歩けないでしょ
歩く時も何か捕まってでも歩かないといけないほど
本人が全く体重を感じないんです
それで足を雲にしたって
もう全然痛みもかゆくも何もないんだから
しっかりと足を背筋を伸ばしてやりたい放題できるんですね
でもあの状態は障害だと理解してもらわないと
これには執着しない それもさっさとこれも確認して確認して
普通に平静に修行を続けていかなくてはならない
で そこはその段階を飛んじゃったらもう安心なんです
大体また二度とは出てこないし
もう悟りの方向に行ってしまっちゃうんです
だからそこはマッガーマッガナーダッサナミスッギと言うんです
どうしますかね そこで道と道でないということは
そこで決める それから道に入ります
それからこの解脱の道に入ります
で 道に入るといったっても
もうあれには束縛されません
怒りにももう体が軽くたって軽くなくたって
も まあそんなこの現象にも関係なく
単なる確認だけして続けていくんですね
とにかく微かにでも執着
囚われがあると上手くいかないんですね
同じ現象がずっと出てきて止まってしまっちゃうんですね
だからそういういろいろ不可思議な現象っていうのは全部馬鹿にしてあげないと
馬鹿にしないと自分でもね
そんなことは何の意味もないんだと
自分がもう輪廻を脱出したいんだと
煩悩をなくしたいんだと
で こちらで入ってないんだけど
ものすごい厳密に音は聞こえる
神々の音を聞こえるとかね
神々を見るとかね お化けを見るとかね
ということもありますけどね
これはまあ初期の時でも
妄想ばっかりの時でも
いろんなこと見えたりしますけどね
まあそこはまあそんなに不思議じゃないんですね
でもはっきりと瞑想成長しちゃうと
もうまたかえって鮮明に見えたり感じたりする場合もあります
そういうのは全部もうバカに
そんなことじゃないんだと
それ先行かなくちゃいけない
先行くと さらにヴィパッサナーする
ヴィパッサナーすると自動的にこういう智慧が生まれてくる
で このアビダンマテキストではこれ書いてないんだから本当に面倒くさいんですね
今日の方にも書いてないんですね
パティパダンニャーナダッサンヴィスッティ
行 定 智 見 清浄 そこでこの九つの智慧が生まれるんです
大体このゆっくり生まれる場合もありまして
瞬時に生まれる場合もあります
まあこれはもう大体もうみんなと同じ
で そういう智慧がないと悟りまでいかない
一番目はこの日本語で書いてますね
壊滅智 これはバンガニャーナというんです
パーリ語で で 確認していくと
なんとなく壊れていくんだ
壊れていくんだ このものはね
壊れていくような感じで
この一つ一つ自分の確認も感じるものも
体の音も この瞬間瞬間も壊れて壊れて壊れて壊れていくんだと
泡のようにはじけてはじけているんではないかというふうに
この気持ちになっちゃうんですね
だから音を聞いてる音
音じゃなくて 音 音と言葉で確認するかもしれませんだけど
この瞬間瞬間が音自体も壊れていて
自分の聴覚自体も壊れて壊れていること
体見ていたっても体の感覚見ていたっても
もう体はもう泡のようにはじけてはじけてはじけて消えて消えていくんじゃないか
だからものは瞬間しか存在しない
それははじけちゃうんですね
そうやって経験するんですね
それからはじけていくと全部
全部壊れていくんだ 全部壊れていくんだ
次に必ず出てくるのは怖さなんです
なんかすごく怖くなっちゃうんですね
なんか居られないほど
それはバヤニャーナと言うんです
何でも頼りにならない
壊れていく すごい怖くなるんですね
怖くなるのはいいんだけど
頼るところがないんですね
だから普通の怖さというよりは大変なものなんです
すっごい恐怖感で覆われちゃうんです
で 覆われても まあもう今はもう非道団体とか
それはもう乗り越えているんだから
瞑想はやっぱり続けちゃう
その時はすごい感情っていうのはものすごいもう大変なところだから
やっぱりあの 一人では無理かもしれません
誰かまあ先輩のところとかね
まあ教える人のところとかね
で そばにいた方がよろしいんですね
大体そのまあ教える側もわかるんですよ
ここら辺に来てくると
最も簡単に まあこの人はもうヴィパッサナーにもう入りましたと
だったらそこはどんな道かということを知ってますから
そこは大体後ろ側もそれなりにまあ用意して準備しているんですね
だからこの観察するものは全部壊れていくということで怖くなってきて
だから他の何かあるかというと
ナームとルーパしかないんですね
心が壊れていく 体が壊れていく
だから何もないでしょう
逃げるとこは 家が火事になったら
じゃあ家を捨てて逃げましょうって言ったら逃げるとこあるでしょ
逃げるところない怖さだから
まあ並の怖さじゃないんです
次になんでしたっけ？これつもまとめて言ってるんですね
アーディーナヴァッサナ
ニッビダーパス ムンチダーガ
パーリ語テキストありますか？それ何のテキスト？注釈パーリ語でありますか？これかわいそうないうちだけどな
これいいんだろうな えーと
なんでなんでしょうか
で怖くなってきたら 逃げるところなくなったから
この この果敢と読むんですかね
アーディーナ まあまあすぐ寸時に
まあもう何の物もないと意味がないという気持ちになっちゃうんですね
だから何でも嫌になるんです
何も意味がない 自分のことも
もうヴィパッサナーについたっても
それにしたってもうもう嫌ですよ
何も意味のないんだと
何したって同じナームとルーパだから壊れていくだけであるということで
すごくこの欠点 短所しか見えなくなっちゃうんです
全て 短所のみ見えてしまう
それからこれはオンリチ
もうこんなもんから逃げた方がいい
離れた方がいいという
このヴィラーガヌパッサナというヴィラーギという智慧が生まれてくるんですね
それでこのナームとルーパの流れがなかった方
ない方がいい ない方がいいという
やっと解脱の気持ちが生まれてくるんです
捨てた方がいい ない方がいいと
脱欲地と書いてるんですね
で なったら大体指導者がないとみんな逃げるんですよ
その場合は すっごいこの強烈な感覚で
感情で かなり自信ないと
かなり智慧がないと で
耐えられないんです 本当の物事の状況を見ると
ですから 指導者がいると
もうあまりにも指導者のことを怖くて
で やっぱり逃げないんですね
たまに道場によって寄ります
変わりますけど この状況になってくると
もう修行する人々なんかそこら辺になってくると
指導する坊さんにはそんなに顔を合わせたりはしませんだけど
そういう日に限って まあそのその人々が瞑想したりするところで
どこかでずっと徹夜して
まあ瞑想したり 歩く瞑想したり
座ったり寝たりしているんですね
だから逃げられないんです
そういう 1日だけはちゃんと守ってあげるんですね
何も言わない 言っちゃったら瞑想の邪魔だからね
やりたくない ものすごくもう逃げたいって気持ちになっても
見たら長老がそこにいるんですね
そこら辺なんとかしながらいるんです
じゃあしょうがないとまた戻っちゃうんですね
そこで瞑想続けちゃいますけども
で 結構あの人たちは感情激しいんです
それでまたやることないんだから
またこの 観察続けちゃうんですね
そこでこの諸作湿地という
まあまだ無常感じるようになってきて
それからサンカーラ サンカールペッカーニャーナ
最後にウペッカーが生まれるんですね
全部捨てたいという気持ちが生まれてきて
それからまあもう全部
まあどう見たっても無常しかないんだと
空しかないんだと ナーマも無常でクも無常
ルーパが無常で 逃げるところもないんだと
で そういうところでまた心が落ち着くんです
あの激しい感情から その落ち着きはサンカールペッカーニャーナといって
仏教では大変ありがたく思うこと
落ち着きなさい その落ち着きから
まあそろそろ悟りが開けるんです
次に 35番目のニャーナだっけなですか
この恐怖感も嫌な気持ちも全部生まれてきて
最終的にはこのもうもう逃げるとこもないし
全て無常であるし 無常から逃げたって無常から無常逃げたって意味がないしね
だから自分という家が火事になっていて
外も火事ですからね 逃げるとこないんですね
どうしますか その場合は
外も火で燃えていて 逃げるとこはない
家に火がついてなかったら安心ですけど
家にも火がついてるんですね
どこまで逃げたっても百キロ逃げたっても全部火事だったら
東西南北どこでも逃げるとこありますか？そこでまず怖くなって泣いたり喚いたりする
でも意味がないんですね
落ち着くんです そのウペッカー
ですから その最初のウペッカーっていうのは
こういうのを普通の人には理解できないほどすごい鋭い知恵の最終段階で
で 生まれてくる知恵なんです
ウペッカーが生まれたら
また何のことなく まあ生滅変化している現象をまた確認することはできるんですね
そこで心が瞬時に解脱を体験しちゃうんです
だからギリギリまで攻めないと解脱はしないんです
このギリギリということは
並のギリギリじゃないんです
ほんのちょっとの苦しみで人の心は解脱しません
例えて言えば 周りは百キロぐらい全部大火事で
自分いるところ 自分の家もものすごく火事になってるんだと
みるみるうちに自分の服にももう火がついてくるんだと
もう逃げるとこないでしょうに
それぐらい心が攻める
空で無常で無我で攻めちゃうんです
そこで でも落ち着きないと悟れない
その時でも まあしょうがないと諦める
そのウペッカーの次 もうほんのちょっとのほんのちょっと
すぐすぐすぐ瞬間にゴートラブという知恵が生まれてきます
その瞬間でウッターナ・ガーミ・ヴィパッサナーと言うんだと
日本語では出器に至る観とも言うと
ウッターナってのは立ち上がるということで
出器と書いてますけどね
で 心が例えば何か観察するでしょ
何でもいいんです その時は
痛みでもいいし 何でもいいんです
全て現象だからね 観察するものはもう無常で
無常ということしか見えなくなっちゃうんです
あるいは空ということしか見えなくなっちゃうんです
だから ある現象が空とたる現象が生まれて
すぐ消えちゃうと 次にまた空という現象が生まれてきて消えちゃう
あるいは無常という現象が出てきて消えちゃうということで
もう取ることなんもなくなっちゃいますから
それでも観察するんだから
これウッターナ 出器 立ち上がるヴィパッサナーと読むんですね
何に立ち上がるか 輪廻からもう立ち上がって
世間の解脱のところに行っちゃうということで
そこであのウペッカーと一緒に
まあ何もとらわれることはない
何にも取ることはない
掴むものは何にもないんだと
何一つもないということで
心っていうのは掴むと認識なんですよ
だから我々認識しているっていうことは
対象を掴まってるんですね
音を掴まって音と聞く
目で入る色を掴まって色だというんです
だから今の瞬間まで無常を体験したことはないんですよ
無常を体験できないんです
そこまで精神的に責められて怖くなって
もう死にたくなって もう逃げたくなっているところまで来てところで
もう逃げる場所どっちもないといったところで落ち着いてきて
そこでやっと何かを無常というものを体験する
無常を体験した瞬間ですぐに悟る
ほんの瞬間 だから掴まることがないという心はこちらでウパチャーラ
あの禁私 禁 禁 禁漁 禁漁というサマーディの前の心
そこで解脱の心と似ている心が生まれちゃう
次の瞬間に 随順心 その解脱と似てる心が生まれた瞬間で次の心はないんです
ないんだけど それは解脱の心なんです
だからずーっと長い間輪廻で心は止まることなく
生まれてきたんだけど
ある瞬間心が止まるんです
そこを解脱と言うんです
その前に解脱と似ている
もう止まる瞬間だから
もうほとんど止まってる状態の心ですから
解脱似てる心が生まれてきて
で 瞬時に解脱が生まれます
で そこはこの途中は止まりません
途中はないんです で 今までは途中がありましたけどね
例えば光が見えてきた人はそこで光で何に悩むかわかりませんだけどね
そういうのあるんだけど
この検校順 随順の心とかね
というのはもうあっという間になんです
そこに解脱の心が生まれる
だからこの解脱と随順する心をこっち書いてるかどうか分かりませんし
書いてないと勝手に説明してたら間違ったら困るし
で 解脱の心生まれる前の心には何と言いますか
守精進が涅槃を所縁として
凡夫の性を超え 聖者の性に達しつつそうじる
このゴートラブーチッタという言葉には名前をつけてるんです
この解脱と全く ウペチャーラ
ウペチャーラ 解脱に似ている心
それからゴートラブというある特別な心が生まれる
その特別な心でもう何も取ることないという気持ちだから
煩悩はなくなっちゃうんですね
大体預流果だったらこの有身見と疑と
えっと何でしたっけ？毀謗取という煩悩三苦ですけど
そんな本人はわからない
そんなどんな煩悩がなくなったかとかね
もうとにかくなんか心が変わったっていう
何もなかったないという
なんかすごいあの捨てるって気持ちさえ生まれるんです
次の瞬間で 心は止まっちゃうんですね
この止まった瞬間で 次の瞬間にまた心が生まれるんです
生まれたらあの瞬間でいかに安らぎでしたかとわかるんです
で そこでもう預流果の悟りなんです
瞬間で生まれて また普通の心が生まれますよ
普通の心が生まれたらいかに安らぎかと観察しますよ
自然に それからもう二度と自分が実体なんかはもうないということは
もうもう体験しちゃったんだから
あのカジノを例えで考えてください
全てがそんなもんだったらまた見れないんだからね
もう逆戻りしない悟りはそこに生まれるんです
それからパッサナンタナーニガ
それで心の流れを説明していますね
それで心は解脱を体験して
次にまた夜だったら夜間という心が生まれてくる
いわゆる解脱の心は夜間の心がそれちょっとほんの一つ二つぐらい生まれてくるんですね
それはすごく楽な心 何の煩悩なく
なんかずっと流れるすごい涼しい楽な心で
で それ終わったらパッチョエッカの後の観察しちゃうんですね
自分が何をやったんですかと
で 観察したところで まあ一つひとまとめて修行は終了なんですね
そこで解脱に特色がありまして
というのは まあここら辺でブッダの終了したっていうのはいいんですけどね
で 無我だとわかって悟った人の解脱にはスンニャタ・ヴィモッカと言うんですね
苦随感という それで無常を分かった人には
無常随感って無常 まあそういう解脱というんですね
苦しみだと分かった悟った人にとってはアッパナヒテ
ムガン・ズイカン ですから
解脱は三種類で名前をつけてるんです
スンニャタ・ヴィモッカ
アニミッタ・ヴィモッカ
アッパナヒタ・ヴィモッカと
だから間違ってる人々は
間違う人々は なんで解脱に三種類あるんですか？とかね
どういう差がですかとか聞きますけど
やっぱりその中で苦を感じることは素晴らしいんではないかとかね
清浄の悟りはあまり良くないとか
いろいろ考え方は出ていますけど
まあこれはもう我々の仏教から見れば
ただ自分が見たのは無常か苦か無我かというそういう違いの差なんです
ではまあ一応ここら辺で
まあもう一回しますか
ないかっていうこと ありますか？ もう一回だけで